et pour en parler nous sommes en direct
depuis standford aux états unis avec
allen
or avocat c'est notre rubrique vu de
l'extérieur à la naure bonsoir merci
d'être en direct avec nous sur rt france
alors c'est donc un sacré enjeu pour
facebook n'est ce pas pourquoi cet enjeu
est il aussi important avec cette
nouvelle présidentielle aujourd'hui je
peux contacter de tous les jours n'a pas
effectué comme une chaîne d'information
c'est est un réseau sous sol où les gens
pouvaient s'exprimer et être en contact
avec leurs amis et leur famille
aujourd'hui c'est devenu une source de
désinformation d'information tous les
syndicats a agi de cette manière de
croire la ville des élections les autres
les autorités cela pourrait poser de
problème et juridiquement c'est
finalement ce que craint le plus la
firme selon vous qu on dise que le géant
fait de la désinformation que l'on dise
que le réseau a faussé le scrutin
abandonné parce que les gens
le réseau social de proximité devenir
louche et les gens pourraient s'en
détourner
et est ce que ce rôle que facebook ce
rôle de censeur que facebook pourrait
éventuellement revêtir ce qu'il est
justifiée par la situation selon vous
[Musique]
ces informations sont vraies mais pas
encore confirmé même sanction je ne sais
pas si on pourrait considérer que
basique serait dans le meilleur sens ce
que l'état américain en tout cas
facebook souhaite ne pas créer de
polémique
ce qui sur le coup reviendrait à crier
feu très remplie donc il faut essayer
d'équilibrer beaucoup de principes que
l'on différents traités fondamentaux
pour les états unis par exemple la
liberté d'expression même temps
s'assurer que les jeunes sont poussés à
des actions extrêmes n'a pas
nécessairement l'intention de gérer cela
et en tout cas elle absente pas les
qualifications peut le faire et en tout
cas il faut que l'association soit plus
équilibré malgré tout est ce que
facebook peut jouer un rôle dans cette
présidentielle
malgré toutes les mesures qui vont être
prises pour éviter la désinformation à
ce que facebook aura ne roule pendant
les semaines qui viennent
[Musique]
c'est le cas de françois réseau social
formation ont été remis aux gens de
construire une idée c'est un acteur
majeur des informations produits par
d'autres raisons je confirme les
informations à votre choix
le problème devient vraiment que même si
facebook devient l'abitre de la vérité
on ne peut pas tout avoir en même temps
merci beaucoup à la naure d'avoir
accepté notre invitation merci pour
votre décryptage ce soir je rappelle que
vous êtes avocat stanford aux états unis